- [Instructor] The snow
outside piled so high
that we couldn't see thorough the window.
All right, so over here they've listed
a bunch of words that
sometimes people confuse.
Or even if you read it real fast,
you might read it the wrong way,
or you might write it the wrong way
if you're doing it really quick.
What we want to say
is that we couldn't through the window.
This right over here, this says thorough.
Thorough means to do something completely,
to do something really
well, to do it thoroughly.
So this right over here, we
don't want to write thorough.
We want to write through.
So we look at the choices here.
So we definitely want to change it,
so we're not gonna pick that.
And so this is the word threw,
but this sounds just like the word we want
but it's a different word.
This is T-H-R-E-W.
This means the past tense
of throwing something,
throwing a ball.
He threw the ball.
So that's not the type
of through that we want.
This one over here, it
has a lot of letters
in common with through.
But this doesn't spell through.
This spells trough.
Trough is kind of where kinda animals
might get their water from,
or it's sometimes viewed as
a low point in something.
It is not through.
So this is not true.
This is trough.
This right over here is
the through that we want.
We want this through.
This means to go through something.
The snow outside piled so high
that we couldn't see through the window,
T-H-R-O-U-G-H,
through the window.
This type of threw, throw a ball.
This is trough.
And what was originally
there, that was thorough,
to do something kind of
really, really completely.